dr clark my best friend
she's dead where are you somebody hit
her with a car
daphne listen to me i know what you're
afraid of i'm not like that anymore
stay where you are oh my god
her phone had you listed as the doctor
to call in case of emergency hey
where's my sister i just want to go see
her is she okay is she
trying to calm down
you need to take a moment to deal with
what's happened
please don't rush yourself losing a
patient is tough
it's a bereavement philip it's dr clark
home i'm james we were just
getting ready to sit down and eat would
you like to join us
i know what you must be going through
and i'm very sorry family's all there is
and you have a great one
what if we were friends
friends
trouble i could take a look
i don't bite
james is gonna list his sister's house
with us really
i'm gonna haunt you i'd like you to find
a new real estate agent i'm not your
enemy doctor clark
i never said you were why is it with you
in that
i'd like to make a formal complaint
against one of your psychiatrists
the administration board wants you to
step aside do you think james is behind
this
yes
why are you looking at me that way like
you don't trust me or something
i appreciate all you've done my husband
and i have a very
different way of dealing with things we
don't talk about it
hey dog there's no hiding right james
flag is very dangerous
stop the car i want to get out he's not
just sick
he's a murderer save the house lock
every single door
[Music]
i still smell her
[Music]
you